no ranked evacuation thank you very much
yes sir and thanks to the organizers for
give me this opportunity to speak here
so I'm gonna talk about lowering
approximations both some theory and
algorithms this is what we've been doing
over the last few years and most of the
people here they're graduate students
some of them are still here some of them
have graduated so they medicine he's at
Google now jdouche he's at the same year
Eric Holman he's still here he should
cry to next year Bali is also here
Jewish oh he's actually going to
Facebook so is shot again
contact so this was supposed to be in
our talk so I'm gonna squeeze a lot of
stuff and I'm gonna speak a lot of
material as well
and yes they already threatened me to
cut me off if I go over 30 minutes so
we're full mostly focus on the theory
part of this and we're going to talk
about what's called a spectrum revealing
QR factorization traditionally there's
something called a drink repeating QR
factorization we're going to review that
and see what the difference is and you
can generalize the idea to most of those
matrix factorizations okay and get
similar results and we're also going to
look at a plot line choice algorithm
this is all for lowering approximations
and there's a number of different
methods that have been developed for
these factorizations and i'm gonna do if
i have time focus on this QR part of
this and i'm gonna skip the rest of
these things
so over the past past few years we have
been submitting these papers and we got
so far five acceptances at these top
machine learning conferences and
typically the acceptance rate is less
than 20% and one over the papers was we
said this best paper what this was like
in 2017 yes okay so what is going us so
we're trying to come up with you know
for any given fact rallies you try to
get the best puzzle bombs and we try to
find methods that can compete these
factors in efficiently and your lower
ranked as like Michael Mahoney would say
sometimes you can preserve sparsity or
structure or maybe like maybe the
comment rolls over the metro city
together something beyond the SPDR we're
not getting into the details but we'll
talk about some of these results if we
have the time
okay so this is a traditional way to
look at their rank really in fact
Rajesh's so what you have is you're
looking at a QR factorization so here
the Q would be orthogonal and this is
gonna be the are part of the matrix pi
is a permutation so what you're doing is
you're reshuffling the columns of a
matrix m and after that you get a QR
factorization this can be a partial
factorization up to this L so
traditionally what we wanted to do was
to figure the new micro rank of a matrix
so that he can do for example Lisa
squares correctly and the focus is in
finding the rank so in this set up what
he can show is that he can find a
permutation pi so that is the leading
piece that al matrix will have all its
singular values 1 to L the J would
signature will be the chase largest
single value
so all these seniors will match the
original senior Mary's up to a constant
factor okay so if here
let's say the chasing value is tiny in
the original matrix this one would also
be tiny that would indicate rank
deficiency so that was the idea so
nowadays if we will do data analysis and
what you want is a lower rate
approximation and not rate elimination
so this by itself does not show you how
you get a lowering approximation or get
it reliably so that is the difference so
what we do is to look at it slightly
differently it's still the same
factorization again this pi is the
column permutation you do a particular
factorization but what we're gonna look
at is not tenacious a rather it's going
to be a or b you cannot throw away the
CL part of the matrix and now you do
analysis so if we find this toj' to be a
ratio of the Sigma values the L here is
going to be the de manual of this error
matrix and the J would be the same index
as the beating can it says next of this
reading single value you take the ratio
of this what you would expect yeah
Marcus thank you so for example
typically you're looking at a data
matrix the senior eyes with the carapace
okay so there's no pretty good clicker
cap in this spectrum but Sigma is
typically decay so if you look for low
rank let's add rank K approximation your
key problem would be here and there will
be somewhere here
the G would be somewhere would be so
deep maybe that would be a better
notation yeah we just didn't change the
notation anyway so we're looking at this
tall J ratio which is going to be Sigma
L plus 1 all that's the Comanche and you
see that if you have a gap in between K
and L they would expect this traitor to
be reasonably small it's not zero but
hopefully it's reason when it's small so
that's why we actually don't get to that
you will we hope that if this is small
day we can hope for this to be really
small as one so if you're looking at
this a of be a part of the matrix then
this matrix not this one but this one
will have seen you Mary's Venus in your
eyes there are a close match to the
original sin of iris after this factor
typically you would expect this to be
small not always but typically that's
the case and if you want to do a low
rank rank approximation then the a
rebound would be find a below and above
but these things and the little the only
action would be this again this is
co-defendant constant so you have capers
when the key is the wreck so if you have
a kids where you seen you guys decay
quickly then even the Tokyo pass one
could be very small in that case you
would get a very good approximation
despite the fact that you only doing QR
factorization okay this is different
then the previous result in that jerk
here you only have a constant factor
right this is a constant demand event
cost so you only get a fraction but here
you could expect to get a very accurate
approximation give the intuition for
while you keep the be around because
your low-rank approximation is going to
be in your combinations of the first
columns of Q right yeah so and what does
the BN you already get that by having a
there if you don't look at a right
that's only just the egg that's L
columns of matrix that B actually
represents the linear combination of the
remaining columns you know the leading
columns
okay so this typically is good I use
this I quoted this would well because
sometimes it's not that good okay so if
you want to do more than tall squared
you could get in at all to the fourth by
doing this to approximation that so you
have M high it was cute
that's this is the typical Q of a
prediction but if you do LP this this is
actually flipped to lower triangle if
you do that then you throw at this piece
the training piece you get an even
better approximation instead with the
power to be two now it's totally the
fourth right and you would ask you know
this not cost much right in fact it
doesn't come very much we're gonna see
some X hopefully we'll see some numbers
what the P is P this is just the you're
doing al P fact rather you know this
matrix
it's like the QR of the transpose of
this image the P would being orthogonal
matrix so I was using the ordinal T but
this is a different thing this is a
lower triangular matrix of a triangle
yeah not the same
okay typically you would do much better
with this okay so example to see all the
differences here you had every power
this is going to be 600 by 600 matrix
and if we do truncate it you are with 60
steps without any column shuffling so
what you get you know you lose the whole
picture if you do trouble eqr with the
column pivoting with success steps you
get some that fits there's some smearing
of the clouds when you get something
okay so typically if you do care with
the column pivoting it's a very slow
operation but if you do a randomized QR
with the column pivoting you will get a
result that's as good numerically but it
will be at a fraction of the original
speed and as you can see this randomized
evolution looks just like this way but
still you see them smearing if we do a
truncated SVD this would be again rank
60 and you can see that this feature
looks well occurs through the original
picture you don't lose something but
looks to the I the difference very small
if we do what we call flip-flop you know
you do the QR and then you do the lq
this thing looks almost the same as this
this is a tiny you probably don't see
the difference to the eye
okay so we've done a lot of different
factorizations here this is a just
summary of what we have done so far and
it turns out that for all the major
nations factorizations you can do the
spectrum revealing motion of it and I'm
gonna skip all the details but you can
compute these factors using efficient
air as well so typically we have the Lu
factorization we have the charts in fact
relation we have the killer
factorization and the sealer and the CX
these are the images of these similar
organizers but all these you can get
these bounds the only difference is in
this tall value I get you know me so if
you do QR the story is - if you do this
flip prop Kiawah this variable toe is 4
but if you do eleocharis key it's 1 so
it's much less accurate if you do C X or
C you are they're just as accurate as
cure
missed a little bit of context on the
under the image factorization you did on
the previous yes is this are you storing
the is your maintenance just every call
is your every night if your matrix best
of one pixel to image border yeah the
grayscale yeah it's a great skill
for these types of spectra the
factorizations like are your pivoting
rules the same as they are for example
for the ALU right it's basically like an
IOU with the column hippedy and with
complete pivoting but we have a way to
compete this quickly typically you don't
do this right it's supposed to be slow
buddy if you do Renoir then you can do
this very quickly and the same thing
with choler ski or even with VC Urca
extract ravishes you have a way to pick
the column payments very quickly Francis
you are competing it's basically you can
think of this as like a successful
iteration on the whole matrix it's also
the stewards method they would score
either P or Q yes that's the S do it q
RP are with him yeah but he does a very
slowly we do it a very quickly so for
the torski do you mean that it is only
applicable to the case when M is the
real symmetric or permission oh yes of
course
[Applause]
so charge ago would be diagonal pivoting
is there any way to you prove the
performance of a trellis key to have a
higher order the question is can you do
this better than that's right you can't
if he really won't work through it it'll
there's better ways to do it
so those are based on matrix track
relations as you can as you saw the best
he could do was for Hawaii or for most
of time this is good but somehow do you
think this is not enough you want to do
better than this if you really want to
get a high quality lowering
approximation you got to do Rockman
chose oplock by regular rice prop by
rotation and this is the math for you
know you're given this V 1 matrix
initial matrix with B columns and you
just do this by diagonalization it stand
everything okay so the details don't
matter but at this point if you want if
you kind of come up with a mathematical
but easier to understand version of this
this is what it is you're basically
calculating the orthogonal space or from
the basis of this subspace column this
mate of K you don't care you don't
tackle it this way but the method
Mathematica this is what it is you get
the basis of all this matrix anything
you do 20 there sweetie
so this a few things to be said the
being is the number of columns in your
Omega which is the initial matrix and
you're looking for a rank K
approximation so we have to kill Q is
the number of steps that needs to be
bigger than K that's the only thing that
you require for this to work in theory
so I mean just put the visa racket it
looks very messy so what we're looking
at is maybe the projection the BK out of
the block Blanche's out of them even
though that language really did not do
this work in particular so you're
looking for rank K approximation you've
done Q steps so this is a lot of
primaries for ruling around but the Q is
the number of steps three is a block
size hey the rate you're looking for
here we introduce another thing called R
this R has nothing to do with the
average it's only part of our analysis
so you're looking at the chase
singing value of this matrix they can
show you that you get at least somewhat
a fraction of the to chase sink value
and a fraction is going to be one plus
of course something which hopefully
would become zero in the end the C is a
constant that's a messy messy constant
we're going to do know the teachers but
what's important is that in the way this
structure the C does not depend on P or
the Q and this part is the capture
polynomial
so
so the comedians depend on this weird
weirdest thing you can all the details
but the point of Sheffield Panama is
that yahweh's this thing this argument
is beyond one yeah then the Chickahominy
Paulo shoots to infinity very quickly so
as not this is a bigger than zero you
hope that your way in great speed this
holding becomes real quickly yes Omega
is part of the sea that's the you to
matrix that's the so the thing is very
messy you know it's very hard to do it's
really hard for the eye to that stay in
a few seconds but this argue which is
part not part of the algorithm it's some
part of visual primary that we introduce
and this is what it is so the question
is what do you do with this ok before we
see what we do with this and it's just
to comparison with what people have
found so far so sod it was the one who
started block line shows this was in the
eighties he had a bad luck test this
Landa could be thought of as Sigma
squared and Moscow this is like a three
years ago they had a really interesting
paper that was for independent lower man
in the film that we're looking at
probably it's something up test there's
some constants and then you have Q
negative 2 and the Q is a number of
iterations so he said surely the idea is
that you would eventually get converges
in the event of the gap no matter what
back a B is you know no matter what
happens to this curve you will get
convergence but numerically this does
not give you very much because you're
cute never exceeds n so all it says is
that you get fraction
and you could introduce of the gaps but
that would be kind of similar to what we
would see in a church in your pound so
our pound is very nice and it has this
artichoke lambda R in it
the R goes into the degree of the
chocolate polynomial but all into the
argument that we get are the smaller
degrees
the bigger the argument this is a
balance right the cup so can this be
zero so here what do you know is that
when your injuries are this ratio right
this guy is big in this guy so what
happens very what happens for the Train
signifiers are equal that's heavy for
they are equal right for this argument
we're going to grow the case that they
are all the same
so Casey weed if they are all the same
you have to grow some of those invites
your method we're not recover those yeah
you know the Melissa T has to be smaller
than the prop size
okay here's the punchline it turns out
that job if you play with all about you
correctly we can show that the bomb we
showed umpires superlinear converges so
that is if you pretend that your major
has elite demand yes yes you know secret
must converge to zero then you have this
thing what's this thing so you can see
it from this plot you're looking at the
converges of the 200th single value
okay and this is with randomized subsidy
iteration which is known to be an
intercollegiate method and this is
popular choice with different prop sizes
and then vertical in hallelujah is is
the number of backpacks the number of
matrix vector multiplies that's a work
that you have done for doing for
commuting the synchronizers as you can
see that these all show super linear
convergence behavior
the bigger the proc size the slower the
converges but still they are so very
near convergent
okay so how much time do I have
I mean it's okay so I'm going to jump
into the Abaddon pot I don't have five
minutes so I get to show you a few plots
these so this is distributed memory
imitation of the spectrum revealing QR
so what you see here is xx of my
twenties on the matrix and here we take
the right to be xx on there as well so
the Lea is that we have the same the
same number of rows it's a square e out
like the PR is the number of processors
and PC the number of processors are so
they you have a square 8 layout over the
processes and the proc size at 64 the P
is 10 that's some like you can feel this
as some kind of L related parameter in
this calculation so the this is the
wrong time what
so we have looked at a number of
different implementations so the there's
the elpac implementation i'm the skill
of an implementation and also a skill in
fact maybe if you just scale it back in
video or something it's supposed to be
faster than the QR with the company and
this is our implementation somewhere
there's also the keyword without company
that's as that's the baseline comparison
so the this is our algorithm this is a
cure without in a concavity and these
are some other skill Apep information
with contacting you can see that we have
a huge smear over these things and this
is a strong scaling of of this of these
algorithms they don't scale very well
that's because for the size twenty
thousand by twenty thousand by the time
you have a lot of processes each process
has very little work to do so that's why
there's no good strong scaling but the
big thing is that there when you start
we are much faster than the other
methods and this is same thing as before
except that at the demand is much bigger
this is a fiftieth other either 20,000
he sees the same kind of behavior these
are random matrices yes maybe because
here we're just going to rule all the
way to the end so it makes little
difference
this is CX and you see you are
this is cor this is yaks so here what
we're looking at is quality versus time
holiday means the ratio between the
convenient chasing values versus the
original chicks think about it so if you
really the one that means you have
captured the scene very correctly if
it's less than one if it's a much less
than one you have not captured it
correctly so this is our method
somewhere here against a render method
regular mutation and some other
competing methods as you can see that if
you don't peep it correctly you don't
get much but the force if we pick pivot
correctly as he increases a rank your
ratios become very close to one but not
one which means that this is not really
if you are looking for high accuracy
approximation this is not very long time
this is QR with random pivoting
this is our method these are the
competing methods we are effective ping
or better than the other matters
that's the see you are this is CX it's
kind of the same kind of behavior this
is random column permutation this is our
method somewhere and these are the
competing methods so for the committee
methods and our method the qualities are
compatible but to our method is here as
first long hammer goes it's a game may
be effective P or more
thank you very much that questions for
me they're like you have a sensibly like
your birth time depends very much on the
block size and it was sort of like
complicated way to have a sense of like
how you should have fixed choose the
font size and you're just like try a
bunch of different ones I see which
converges faster or like yeah you like
this one yeah okay so I know the or
doesn't okay so as far as
commodious goes the smaller the block
size the better right so this is because
one that should chew this is I think for
its wonderful fun so as wise and with
your speed goes somewhat of a rock size
is better but on the other hand
performance depends on bigger block size
so this plot by itself does not hear you
which be body is better but our
experiment seems to suggest that AB
equals y is better because because our
allows much easier handling of deflation
all that kind of stuff if your B is
bigger than one because it's lower
that's right but then there's a lot of
other issues that will become so much
simpler when B is 1
that question yes I was wondering about
the sort of penetration going from top
of the to 2004 and sort of missing like
a uniqueness thing here or is possible
to sort of to train more so this is the
slightly at women right yeah so this is
where the value is so it's actually I
used to the raw value if you do arrow
you right like I mean it's so simple you
probably should
[Music]
so I don't know what you mean by
uniqueness because by the time you're
doing this you're just doing
approximation right so the polymer you
do this then this the column committee
itself is not going to be very important
so you can continue doing this but this
amounts to subspace iteration which I
already said in this plot so if you're
really into convergence you want to have
higher accuracy you do plan chose
let's defer any remaining questions to
line segments thank me again also
contract you make him on this most
people think
[Applause]